♪ MacGRUBER ♪
♪ MAKING LIFE
MacGRUBER
YOU NEED AN ANIMAL FOR ♪
♪ STICKY SITUATIONS
MacGRUBER
THE GUY'S A FREAKING ♪
♪ GENIUS
MacGRUBER ♪
>> DAMMIT, THIS DOOR IS PRESSURE
SEALED.
WE'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE!
>> MacGRUBER, IF WE DON'T
DISMANTLE THE C4 EXPLOSIVE, THIS
WHOLE BUILDING IS GOING TO BLOW
SKY HIGH.
60 SECONDS.
>> OKAY, DON'T WORRY, GANG, WE
CAN DO THIS IF WE WORK TOGETHER
AS A TEAM.
AND LOOK, I KNOW THIS WHOLE
COVID SITUATION HAS REALLY
CHANGED THE GAME, SO WE GOT TO
BE SMART ABOUT THIS, OKAY?
WE'RE IN A SMALL ROOM WITH VERY
LIMITED AIRFLOW.
>> GOOD CALL.
>> YEAH, GREAT THINKING,
MacGRUBER.
>> OKAY, VICKI, PASS ME THAT OLD
TIN.
>> YOU GOT IT, MacGRUBER.
>> PIPER, THAT LIGHTER FLUID.
>> COMING AT YOU, GRUBS.
>> NOW BOTH OF YOU, HAND ME YOUR
MASKS.
>> WHAT?
>> NO TIME TO EXPLAIN, MASKS
NOW!
>> MacGRUBER, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
>> FREEING US FROM TYRANNY,
VICK.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> WELCOME FOR WHAT?
I REALLY WANTED TO WEAR THAT
MASK.
>> YEAH, YOU JUST SAID YOURSELF
THAT WE'RE IN A SMALL ENCLOSED
ROOM.
>> YES, SO WE NEED EVERY DROP OF
OXYGEN WE CAN GET, WHICH IS
IMPOSSIBLE WITH THESE STUPID
FACE DIAPERS.
I CAN FINALLY BREATHE.
>> I'VE GOT TO SAY I'M A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS.
>> DON'T WORRY, VICK.
I'M VAXED AND RELAXED.
HERE'S PROOF.
>> I THINK THERE'S A "P" MISSING
AT THE BEGINNING OF PFIZER.
>> MADE OF A SIZLER?
>> SURE DID, PIPER.
>> AND VICKI, IF THERE WAS A "P"
IN FRONT OF PFIZER, IT WOULD BE
PRONOUNCED P-FIZER.
>> JUST ADMIT YOU'RE NOT
VACCINATED.
>> OKAY, FINE, YOU FREAKING
KAREN.
I'M NOT GETTING THAT STUPID
SHOT, ALL RIGHT, 'CAUSE I DON'T
WANT THE GOVERNMENT PUTTING A
TRACKING DEVICE IN MY SCROTUM.
>> EW.
>> MacGRUBER, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T NEED TO KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT, PIPER,
BECAUSE I HAVE A BRAIN.
BECAUSE YOU TWO SHEEPLE ARE SO
FREAKED OUT, LET ME ASSURE YOU,
I'M TOTALLY ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> I'M NOT SURE WE HEARD YOU
RIGHT.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS.
>> I THINK THE WORD YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR IS ASYMPTOMATIC.
>> YES, THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> NO, I DEFINITELY SAID I'M
ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> YEAH, YOU DID.
>> SO WHAT'S THE ISSUE HERE?
>> MacGRUBER, 10 SECONDS!
>> LOOK, WE MAY NOT ALL AGREE ON
THIS HOAX VACCINE, BUT ONE THING
WE CAN ALL AGREE ON IS THAT I DO
KNOW HOW TO DEFUSE BOMBS.
>> 1 SECOND, MacGRUBER!
>> OKAY, PIPER, HAND ME
♪ MacGRUBER ♪
♪ MACGRUBER
HE DID A LOT OF READING
AND HE'S GOT A NEW ALBUM
MACGRUBER
HE REALIZED THERE WAS ♪
♪ MORE THAN JUST
ONE SIDE TO THIS
ISSUE ♪
♪ MACGRUBER
HE'S FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE
NOW
MACGRUBER ♪
[ SIRENS ]
>> SHOOT!
THIS VAULT DOOR'S WELDED SHUT.
THERE'S NO WAY OUT.
>> AND FROM THE LOOKS OF OUR
DYNAMITE BOMB WE'VE ONLY GOT
60 SECONDS BEFORE THIS WHOLE
PLACE IS BLOWN TO BETSY.
>> NOT A PROBLEM, GANG.
WE GOT THIS.
DON'T WORRY.
AFTER THE LAST MISSION I'VE
HEARD YOUR CONCERNS AND NOW I'M
FOLLOWING ALL THE PROTOCOLS.
>> WELL MACGRUBER, THERE'S A BIG
HOLE IN YOUR MASK.
>> UH YEAH, SO I DON'T SUFFOCATE
FROM ALL THE CARBON DIOXIDE,
DUH.
[ COUGH ]
LOOK, THERE'S NO REASON TO BE
SCARED.
I'M GOING TO BE FINE.
I'VE DONE A TON OF RESEARCH AND
I'M FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE NOW.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> OKAY.
VICKY, PASS ME THAT IVERMECTIN.
>> OKAY, HERE.
>> PIPER, THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> HERE.
>> MacGRUBER, YOU HAVE COVID?
>> HELL NO.
>> OH, THANK GOD.
>> I HAVE COVID PLUS.
IT'S A COVID STRAIN MIXED
WITH -- SOMETHING ELSE.
>> OH!
>> SYPHILIS.
>> YOU GOT IT.
GOOD ON YOU.
DO YEAH, COVID, SYPHILIS.
AND I DO HAVE AN UNCONNECTED
FREESTANDING HERPES IN THERE AS
WELL.
I ALSO HAVE HORSE WORMS SO THIS
IVERMECTIN IS PULLING DOUBLE
DUTY.
>> YOU HAVE HORSE WORMS?
>> OH, YEAH, A BUNCH OF THEM.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> OH THAT'S DISGUSTING.
>> RELAX, IT'S JUST SPAGHETTI.
DOWN HERE IN MY JOCKEYS, JUST
WAITING FOR THE RIGHT MOMENT TO
SPRING THIS LITTLE JOKE ON YOU.
PUNK'D!
A LITTLE AL DENTE.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE HORSE WORMS?
>> NO, I DO HAVE HORSE WORMS.
OH, LOOK, THEY'RE CHOMPING ON
THE SPAGHETTI.
LEAVE THAT ALONE, YOU LITTLE
TURKEYS.
THAT'S MY FOOD.
I'M NOT GONNA EAT THIS NOW.
>> MacGRUBER, THE BOMB!
>> OKAY, PIPER, HAND ME THAT
TOILET PAPER WITH DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI'S FACE ON IT.
>> HERE.
>> VICKY, HAND ME THAT "LET'S GO
BRANDON" T-SHIRT.
>> HERE YOU GO, MacGRUBER.
>> SO FUNNY, HUH?
IT'S ACTUALLY MADE OF SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> YEAH, WE KNOW.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
>> YOU'VE GONE DOWN SOME
AT-RIGHT MISINFORMATION RABBIT
HOLE.
>> YOU'RE ALT WRONG ABOUT THAT,
KAREN.
MY INFORMATION IS
100% NON-INSANE.
EVER HEARD OF QANON?
[ EXPLODES ]
♪ MacGRUBER ♪
♪ MacGRUBER
HE KIND OF SPIRALED OUT ♪
♪ DOWN AN INTERNET
RABBIT HOLE ♪
♪ MacGRUBER
HE LOST SOME FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND FAMILY AND THEY
STAGED AN INTERVENTION ♪
♪ MacGRUBER
HE'S GOT IT ♪
♪ BACK TOGETHER NOW
MacGRUBER ♪
>>> LOOKS LIKE WE'RE TRAPPED,
MacGRUBER.
>> AND A HYDROGEN BOMB IS SET TO
BLOW IN 30 SECONDS!
>> SO WHERE WAS I?
OH, YES.
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES ARE EATING
BABIES.
THEY DEVOUR THEM.
THEY'RE INSATIABLE.
LIKE THE WAY HORSE WORMS EAT
SPAGHETTI.
RAW BABIES, COOKED BABIES.
I'M SURE THEY HAVE A VARIETY OF
RECIPES.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT
THERE AND NOBODY IS DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> CAN WE CONCENTRATE ON THE
BOMB?
>> OH, THAT'S NOT A BIG ENOUGH
BOMB FOR YOU TO FIND OUT THAT
ELLEN POMPEO EATS BABIES?
>> I KNEW IT.
>> YOU'RE SO BRAINWASHED.
>> I'M SORRY, IN WHAT WAY?
>> JUST LOOK AT HOW YOU'RE
DRESSED.
>> FORGIVE ME FOR NOT SHOPPING
AT CHEAPS-R-US LIKE YOU.
I'M JUST YOUR AVERAGE AMERICAN
WHO BELIEVES IN LIMITED
GOVERNMENT, MY BODY, MY
CHOICE -- FOR MEN -- AND
SUPPRESSED VOTING RIGHTS FOR
ALTERNATIVELY SKINNED PEOPLE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT MAKES ME
BRAINWASHED.
>> MacGRUBER, WE DON'T HAVE TIME
FOR THIS.
>> MacGRUBER, FOCUS.
PLEASE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, OKAY.
VICKY, HAND ME ALL THE REMAINS
OF AMERICA'S SOUL.
>> WHAT?
THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
WELCOME TO THE REAL WORLD.
LOOK, I'M JUST A SHAMAN.
>> ALL I CAN DO IS PRAY FOR YOU,
TAKE UP ARMS AGAINST YOU, AND
KEEP THE OATH I TOOK TO PROTECT
THIS COUNTRY.
BECAUSE I AM AN OATH KEEPER AND
BOY AM I PROUD OF THAT.
WHICH I GUESS MAKES ME A PROUD
BOY.
>> DO YOU EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT NOW?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> MacGRUBER, IF WE DON'T DEAL
WITH THIS BOMB, WE ARE GOING TO
EXPLODE.
>> 5 SECONDS.
>> ACCORDING TO CNN.
>> 4 SECONDS.
>> CANCEL CULTURE.
>> 3 SECONDS.
>> NOT MY CLOCK.
>> 2 SECONDS.
>> HOLLYWOOD ELITE.
>> 1 SECOND.
>> THOUGH I DO KIND OF LIKE SOME
STREAMERS ON PEACOCK.
♪ MacGRUBER ♪♪